[Musique]
bienvenue à sa pierre à l'entreprise ses
clients
[Musique]
bonjour taper la nasse gagne j'ai ton
trois ans s'est marié j'ai deux enfants
j'ai été responsable de magasin pendant
dix ans et aujourd'hui j'ai lancé mon
entreprise qui soit appelle ses clips
alors pour me lancer je suis d'abord
parti voir un expert comptable qui m'a
conseillé sur les différents statuts ou
une entreprise j'ai été accompagné par
la chambre des métiers je suis également
partie voir le pôle emploi où ils m'ont
conseillé de prendre les salariés tout
d'abord en atr donc c'est un contrat
aidé pour pouvoir voir si l'entreprise
plus hauts salariés ici le salarié plaît
à l'employeur mais une fois que les 299
eur été fait est que le salarié me
plaisait il avait automatiquement ainsi
dit
alors c'est clean certains un magasin
spécialisé dans le nettoyage auto dans
le service rapide la première nous avons
aussi une partie boutique le nettoyage
nous proposons le lavage intérieur
extérieur classique on propose également
un collage des sièges en profondeur dans
un shampoing siège pays lustrage les
rénovations nous proposons également le
service rapide donc on peut s'occuper de
chaque véhicule a jusqu'à z des
pneumatiques disques et plaquettes
révision vidange patrie vous essuie
glaces on s'occupe vraiment de mettre la
voiture du client le plus clean possible
à tous les niveaux donc on s'occupe
vraiment de
de confort du client en allant récupérer
sa voiture à une heure précise la
ramener à une heure précise donc notre
force aujourd'hui c'est notre proximité
avec les clients on essaie vraiment de
s'adapter aux besoins du client de
faciliter son quotidien
nous avons également la partie boutique
donc pour tous les passionnés de lavage
auto qui aiment laver leurs véhicules
eux-mêmes donc on propose toute la gamme
de produits en magasin mais pour
toujours la gamme pro la gamme de
particuliers on a tout ce qu'il faut
pour le plaisir de
alors au tout début on a commencé à deux
donc avait judicaël et moi uniquement de
lavage auto et ont vu la forte demande
que je commençais à avoir le physique
pourquoi pas embaucher quelqu'un d'autre
part le pôle emploi ils m'ont proposé
plusieurs formules au niveau des aides
j'ai eu de la chance de tomber sur des
profils vraiment intéressant et sympa
qui était dans le pré caire où j'ai
voulu emmener avec une certaine
stabilité dans qu'avec un cdi rené à
sept mois compris donc g5 cdi un
apprenti et donc moi ce que j'aimerais
aller on a déjà un site internet qui est
en cours de création donc créé encore un
emploi pour que quelqu'un puisse gérer
le site internet et surtout s'occuper
également des livraisons dans toute
l'île dès l'année prochaine j'aimerais
beaucoup lancé le lavage à domicile et
s'occupait également des canapés y ait
des tapis de tout ce qui concerne la
maison également et là je pourrais créer
encore si tout se passe bien deux
emplois
le plus grand échec et de ne pas avoir
le courage de vue